the thing i'm researching at the moment
and a big part of my live show is
actually i'll be talking about black
holes and that's because black holes are
the most baffling and interesting things
and i could talk about them forever um
but one of the questions that was asked
initially by stephen hawking actually by
work he did back in the 70s was what
happens to stuff that falls in
does the the information if you throw a
book into a black hole
is the information gone from the
universe forever
and he discovered that black holes and
this really was
what stephen hawking is most famous for
in physics he discovered that black
holes evaporate away over time it's
called hawking radiation and so one day
they're gone
so the question is is the information
gone
and for many years many years even
thought that the information was
destroyed in black holes
and then he changed his mind
and now the current view is that no the
information comes out and we're pretty
sure now almost completely sure that
information survives that process of
going into a black hole gets radiated
out into the universe and in some sense
it's never lost um but there's there's
you know one of the great physicists of
the 20th century in 21st century stephen
hawking changing his mind because he got
a deeper understanding and more work was
done and that's what science is all
about yeah
thank you those are great stories and
especially from someone brilliant like
yourself and explaining how you change
your mind and someone like stephen
hawking
um okay well then let's talk about black
holes
because i find it fascinating as well
maybe we'll back up and start with
energy just the
just the universal understanding and
maybe this is i think this is accurate
correct me if i'm wrong um that energy
can't be destroyed it's only transformed
so
everything is energy
right so even if a book went in there
it's some form of energy is this correct
yeah with that in mind then transformed
could it what could it become like what
could the things that fall into the
black hole become presumably it doesn't
always have to come out as a book right
if we're just using that exactly well no
so so the thing if you think about
something like a book
um and then if we wind back um how does
physics work as we understand it at the
fundamental level it says that if you
know everything about something let's
say a book
and then let's say we burn the book so
we set it on fire
then physics says that if we could
collect everything all the gas and all
the ashes and everything and measure
everything that came off from that fire
perfectly which is very hard to do but
if we could do it
then we could run back time and
reconstruct the book okay um so given
that we know everything about something
or with a great deal of precision at
some moment we can predict what it's
going to do in the future and what it
was doing in the past that's called
determinism
that's central to science it's how we
how we look at the universe today and
try and we model it and run it back in
time and forwards in time and we see the
big bang and we can measure the time
back and all those things
so
the question with black holes is
is that still true
so it is if we could collect everything
that comes off the black hole when it's
evaporated away through this process
called hawking radiation and it's just
particles nothing left the black hole's
gone
could some omnipotent being right in the
far future with a huge quantum computer
feed everything in
and then reconstruct
everything that fell in
and the laws of nature
as we understand them at the basic level
say yes
but the laws of nature also said
as we understood them at the basic level
with the black hole initially they said
no
so we had a clash a fundamental clash
um between our with our laws of nature
contradicting themselves right
essentially that's the that was the
wonderful thing about black holes
and it turns out that now
it seems that no the the ultimately as
the black hole evaporates away the
information that fell in
uh gets imprinted into the radiation
that comes off the black hole which is a
really tremendously bizarre thing to
happen
um and it's really what it's done is
it's challenged us
to reassess our understanding of space
and time
and and now
the
the the the consensus view i think from
the black hole research
is that space and time are not
fundamental things
that they emerge from something deeper
einstein had this wonderful phrase
something deeply hidden he said when you
look at nature in detail you can catch a
glimpse of something deeply hidden which
is the deep structure of nature and it
seems that there is such a structure of
space and time
and what that deep structure which is
what we call quantum theory preserves
information
so the patterns the patterns evolve and
change over time but the patterns are
always there and you can always if you
could collect them and you were smart
enough you could run it back and see the
patterns in the past
so one of the most fascinating things
within science to me is fractals
like i just think fractals is
fascinating i constantly look at the way
things are and
just wonder what level like what what
part of the fractal loop we're in
is it is our universe completely is it
fractal in nature
i i think at a deep level it isn't so
fractal there's a great thing if you go
online you can look at the mandelbrot
set which is this this um mathematical
structure
ultimately and and you can you can zone
in i when i was little actually so i'm
being really geeky now i wrote a
computer program to draw one it's a
really simple thing
and in this really simple bit of
mathematics is this infinitely complex
structure and as you zoom in and then
and then you see the structure again and
the structure again and structure again
so i really recommend you go online and
look at mendelbroset and spend an
afternoon or an evening zooming in and
exploring this bizarre land that's
mathematical
um so you can go infinitely deep
basically and carry on and you just see
pattern after pattern after pattern
repeating itself
um
with the universe what black holes have
told us is that the universe
isn't like that there's a really
weird strange results from black hole
physics
and it's that so let's say i say to you
how much information
in bits right so literally in bits of
information like the memory in your
phone how much can i put in some given
region of space
so you could look at the region of space
in front of you now just look in front
of your nose look at a little cubic
centimeter or something of space
whatever it is and say how much
information could i put in there
um the answer is
that the maximum amount of information
you can fit is you keep putting bits in
and ultimately the thing collapses into
a black hole right
so there's kind of a limit before you
make a black hole and the whole thing
collapses
and the amount of information in any
given region of space
seems to be proportional
or actually equal in some
sense to its surface area and not its
volume
so that's like saying if i was to ask
you how many books can you put in a
library how much information can you fit
in the library you'd say well it's got
to do with how many books i can fit in
it's to do with the volume of the room
how many books can i get in the room
that's it or how many hard disks or
whatever it is
but it turns out at a fundamental level
nature seems to say no
it's only about the surface
it's not about the inside at all
and so this is leading us to think that
we vastly overestimated the amount of
information you can store in any given
region of space
um and this leads to something called
the holographic principle that we could
talk about which is um
i love it i read the holographic
universe
so
a hologram is
the basic level it's it's a piece of
film right so a flat thing
like a sheet of paper two-dimensional
thing with all the information on it
necessary to make a three-dimensional
image of a thing
and it seems that a very deep level the
universe is like that
and people are even it came from black
hole research but people are even now
although it's not fully understood by
any means
beginning to say well okay so that means
that
there's an equivalent description of us
so me and you and everyone that's
listening and watching there's an
equivalent description which is some in
some sense and physicists always use
that phrase by the way when they're
waving their hands around right in some
sense right so it means we don't fully
get that right we don't fully understand
it but in some sense
the the the information our thoughts and
everything that we experience is is
equally well represented on a surface
surrounding us so it's almost it is it's
a and in that sense you could say that
we're holograms and that's called a
holographic principle and that's really
bizarre but it's coming from research in
black holes
hmm what part of the black hole is that
all the information's on the outside
well so the problem with a black hole is
that from the outside
the thing behaves in a certain way and
that's how we view it right so we're out
we see one there's a there's a galaxy
called m87 for example about 55 million
light years away and we have a
photograph of the black hole
in that galaxy and it's a huge black
hole six billion times the mass of the
sun supermassive black hole so we know
these things exist we've got a picture
of one in that galaxy
and so from the outside um they're weird
right so if i was to if if i said to you
you go into the journey into the black
hole
and i watched you go in so i sat from
afar and watched you fall in
i would i would never see you cross into
the black hole
you would you would freeze on what's
called the event horizon
and it's actually
from some perspectives i could i could
imagine that you actually were
completely incinerated on the event
horizon and all your ashes came out into
space and i could collect them and i
could reconstruct you right if i was
clever enough
so i could do that but yeah
but from your perspective you would fall
in across the horizon inside of the
black hole you go into the interior of
the black hole you could float around in
there in the interior of the m87 black
hole for i think it's about 35 hours or
something if i remember rightly before
you meet the end of time
so you go to the end of time ultimately
in the black hole so from your
perspective you go in and you end your
days at the end of time which is called
the singularity in the black hole
whereas from the external perspective
you never cross the horizon so you're
saying if you watched it i wouldn't
change but so what goes in my
consciousness my no you would you would
go in
there's a thing called the equivalence
principle in relativity fundamental to
einstein's theory which says that you
wouldn't notice
so you you could fall in across the
horizon of the black hole into the
interior and you would notice nothing
you'd sit there looking at your watch
you would tick at one second per second
you would feel no ill effects at all in
you go but from the external perspective
you never get in
um and uh
so the the modern understanding is that
both are true
so our universe is constructed in a very
strange way where things that you might
think are a contradiction um actually it
just depends on your point of view
whether you got in or not um but the
outcome
it ultimately is the same so no
contradictions appear and that's been
central to black hole research it's got
a fancy name it's called black hole
complementarity and it's broadly
speaking thought to be correct
now but it really it challenges us to
think about what we mean by reality
because it means that our reality is
so strange
so much stranger than we could possibly
have imagined still work still works the
laws of nature apply
but it's not quite what we expected you
know our common sense is not a good
guide